why not show you the photo you like
spicy food I love spicy food
I'm in pain but I like it it's a good
pain it's weird there was a good time
when I thought Taco Bell was spicy
though I was like been training for this
moment though I've been adding spice in
little by little so it's like truth or
dare but truth or spicing who goes first
I think I think you should do you want
me to do it yeah
spicy turkey who is someone you can't
stand and why I think you should eat the
jerky or demon name
I don't have any names although he
betrays you I actually I love you want
to try this Oh
currently that Reaper I think the
Carolina Reapers are like the spiciest
pepper that's alive
that's so much not bad is it that how
bad it's just don't breathe when you
need it all right okay my turn
roll she was like em ElastiCache aha yup
Yolo hook what is the most illegal thing
you've ever gotten away with it's not
bad I kind of just want to take the shot
okay that enough
yes hey I haven't done anything not
illegal I've just stolen things but you
know what I don't want to glorify what I
did so for the kids I'm doing this okay
boom whoa sorry I gave you a feel alive
the first time
take a look at it yeah take a look I'm
gonna take a question this looks amazing
I would just eat it what is your most
Awkward public poop story oh I do not
have one I wish like I had one so I can
like maybe you want to eat more you can
eat more mmm that's good
is it good that's good I kind of want to
taste it it's a pretty good you know
alone it's more salty than I'll wait mmm
I guess it gets spicy
I got spicy for me do you have napkins
mm-hmm don't touch your eyes I know oh
it's you
maybe I might even too much I'm sweating
a bit chilly got Baron von air pepper
it's a little too spicy oh it's not
eating that one peanut made me a little
nervous
wait what yeah you want I eat like eight
yeah I know
you're calm
[Music]
Thank You Robin
spicy Robin have you ever sent a sexy
photo of yourself is that even in let's
define sexy photo naked make it yeah so
many freaking times I take them just for
fun okay I'm not even concerned if my
phone gets hacked and then get out there
I'm just like yeah whatever okay like
it's true I'm gonna skip it
the answers the questions yes this is
something that I don't want to do it was
wrong yeah it was rough how many people
have you kissed I don't know I mean I
can't do you really want to be like
estimate jeez do you wanna do you want
to do the shot I'll do the shot not bad
right spicy chocolate
that sounds good like that sounds good
looks a little suspicious see any brand
I'm very small too so okay show me the
sixteenth photo in your camera bowl from
the bottom up no we talked about this I
mean I show it to the camera
IRA sent a sexy photo naked naked yeah
so many freaking time because I take
them just for fun okay you just want to
eat the shot oh
Oh spicy spicy Oh actually it looks very
harmless no way it's not that spicy no
it's not is it really I'm okay
okay I'm sweating it's in my throat come
I need a drink I wish I just showed you
my naked photo oven
you know a little you know I feel okay
yes is it painful yeah why not show you
the photo I could have been your selfie
just a harmless old what if it's someone
else oh my god might as well drink the
whole bottle geez who is one person you
pretend to like but actually don't
describe your relationship with the
person my boss
definitely my limit your school teachers
yeah teachers bosses friends boyfriends
or girlfriends yeah what MA one of my
best friend's girlfriend I had to
pretend like I like that which would but
nobody did it's you know white lies I
think are good sometimes I'm feeling
better every one so
[Music]
Oh what is in your web history that
you'd be embarrassed to come out I'm
trying to think of a creative answer
right now did you eat the jerky that's
pretty big he's got some flakes in there
the bigger the bigger the piece the size
here it is this is really ready
yeah I'm not crying yeah
no no my name is this do you think
you'll marry the person you're currently
dating yes baby and I don't have to eat
that chocolate can I eat it just for the
curiosity yeah eat it
I think nothing on this table compares
to that chocolate yeah I feel you know I
understand thank you I feel feedback I'm
good why did I decide to volunteer I
learned that you're very kind and sweet
person Evan thank you you know what you
really are
I've learned chocolate could be very
spicy if you see a gold wrapped
chocolate on the street please don't eat
it
[Music]